Guten Tag. Ich bin der zuständige Arzt für Sie. Das ist mein Name. Wie heißen Sie?
Guten Tag. Mein Name ist Rolf.
Gräulich.
Herr Gräulich, können Sie bitte Ihren Vor- und Nachnamen standieren?
Aber natürlich. Mein Vorname ist Rolf.
Ludwig Friedrich. Nachname ist Gräulich. Gustav Richard.
Emi Udo. Ludwig Ida. César Heinrich. Gräulich.
Okay. Gräulich. Bevor wir anfangen, lassen Sie mich Ihre persönliche Daten notieren.
Danach kümmere ich mich um Ihre Beschwerde. Okay?
Gerne, natürlich. Okay. Wie raten Sie?
Ich bin 54 Jahre alt. Okay. Verraten Sie mir mit der Geburtstagung?
Oh, das wollen Sie auch noch wissen. Das ist der 23. Mai.
Okay.
1954. Okay. Wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ein bisschen zu viel. Wiege im Moment so ca. 94 kg.
Okay. Herr Gräulich. Und wie groß sind Sie?
Ungefähr 1,75 m.
Okay. Sind Sie verharatet?
Ja.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Zwei Kinder habe ich, ja.
Okay. Und was sind Sie von Beruf?
Ich bin Kfz-Mechaniker.
Also, Frau Herr Gräulich, was kann ich für Sie tun?
Also, Herr Doktor, leider hat mein Hausarzt heute Nachmittag zu.
Aber deswegen komme ich heute zu Ihnen.
Okay.
Ich habe seit ca. 2 Tagen zunehmende Schmerzen an meiner rechten Warte.
Und das ist auch so ein bisschen druckempfindlich,
wenn ich mit meiner Hand an so eine Wehne bestimmte Stelle komme.
Und das wird auch ein bisschen rot.
Okay.
Ist Ihnen etwas aufgefallen, dass die Warte geschwollen ist?
Ja, das stimmt.
So, wo ich mich frage, das sieht ein bisschen dicker aus als das linke Bein.
Seit 2 Tagen.
Ja, und das wird...
Okay, vorher haben Sie auch solche Probleme gehabt?
Ich hatte vor vielen Jahren mal ähnliche Probleme gehabt.
Das stimmt ja.
Wann war genau das?
Das sind ungefähr 5 Jahre her.
5 Jahre her.
Und haben Sie dagegen zum Arzt gehen gegangen?
Sind Sie dagegen zum Arzt gehen gegangen?
Deswegen war ich beim Arzt, ja.
Damals hat gesagt, das ist eine Trombose.
Eine tiefe Bein-Wähntrombose.
Und ich musste über 1 Jahr so blutfördünnende Medikamente nehmen.
Und jetzt habe ich die Angst, dass es vielleicht etwas Gleiches oder Ähnliches ist.
Okay.
Nehmen Sie noch diese Medikamente ein?
Nein, nicht mehr, als du seid.
Jetzt 2 Jahre nicht mehr.
Aber ich hatte schon mehrere Trombosen gehabt.
Was für Trombose hatten Sie?
Einmal am linken Bein, einmal dann am rechten Bein.
Und ich hatte aber auch eine Lungenirrambulier schon mal gehabt.
Okay.
Das liegt schon länger zurück. Das sind circa 10 Jahre.
Ja.
Und man hat mich deswegen auch zu einem Spezialisten geschickt.
Okay.
Und der hat auch mein Blut untersucht und meinte, das ist alles in Ordnung.
Das gibt keine Hinweise für eine Gerinnungsstörung.
Habt jetzt nicht.
Okay.
Deswegen, die haben alle mit Kommentar abgesetzt.
Ja, ich bin immer in Kontrolle.
Ich bin auch bei einem Gefäß Spezialisten.
Der schaut hier nach meinen Gefäßen, nach den Beinen.
Und bisher war eigentlich alles in Ordnung.
Also, waren wir jetzt in Kontrolle?
Das war circa einem Jahr.
Okay.
War alles in Ordnung.
Und am Ende, Sie sehen, ich trage normalerweise immer Stützstrümpfe.
Mhm.
Und ich war am Wochenende auf einer Reise mit dem Auto.
Wie viele Stunden hat dieser Reise gedauert?
Das war schon länger.
Das war so vier Stunden mit dem Auto, bin ich gefahren.
Vier Stunden.
Und obwohl ich immer zwischendurch auch immer eine Pause eingelegt habe.
Okay.
Und wann war diese Reise genau?
Ich meine, vor drei Tagen.
Also, nach dieser Reise sind diese Beschwerden aufgekriegt.
Ja, genau.
Also, Sie haben schon gesagt, dass die Schmerzen haben.
Wie könnten Sie mir sagen, wie genau die Schmerzen sind?
Sind sie eher dumpf oder stechend oder krampferartig?
Ja, es ist eher dumpf, aber es geht über die ganze Wade.
Aber wie Sie hier sehen, hier an dieser Wade ist ein dickes Gefäß.
Eine Wenig, das ist auch sehr prall.
Wenn man so auf die Wenig drauf drückt, das tut dann weh.
Okay.
Und haben Sie Fieber?
Nein, Fieber habe ich nicht.
Okay.
Haben Sie Unfall gehabt?
Ach so, nein.
Ich hatte keinen Trauma, keinen Unfall, keine Verletzung.
Das haben wir jetzt nicht.
Ist Ihnen irgendwelche Ungefüllnisches aufgefallen?
Ich meine, haben Sie noch irgendwelche Beschwerden?
Nein, habe so Schmerzen.
Schwellung ist da eine Rötung.
Sonst habe ich im Moment erst mal nichts.
Das reicht doch, das ist genug, mehr will ich nicht haben.
Ja, wir haben recht.
Okay, jetzt möchte ich über Ihre Erkrankungen einfach Frage stellen.
Sie hatten mehrmals Thrombose.
Und außer diese Krankheiten, leiden Sie noch irgendwelche an chronische Erkrankungen?
Wie Blutdruck, Diabetes.
Ja, in der Tat, das ist sehr gut.
Ich habe einen bekannten hohen Blutdruck.
Da nehme ich auch Medikamente ein.
Was nehmen Sie genau?
Medikamente?
Ja.
Das ist zum einen das Kandesatan.
Okay.
Wie viel Milligramm?
16 Milligramm.
Wie viel Mal?
Einmal am Morgen.
Und dann habe ich das Amnodipin.
Das sind glaube ich 5 Milligramm.
Und die nehme ich dann am Abend.
Und außer Blutdruck, gibt es noch etwas?
Ja, mein Doktor meinte, ich habe so einen beginnenden Diabetes.
Er hat mir auch gleich Medikamente verschrieben.
Da nehme ich, wie heißt das nochmal, Metromin.
Also seit wann?
Seit 500 Milligramm.
Okay, wie viel Mal?
Wie oft?
Zweimal, am Morgen und am Abend.
Seit wann haben Sie jetzt gerade Krankheit?
Seit wann?
Ah so, das ist ungefähr seit einem Jahr.
Seit einem Jahr, also 5, 2.
Ja, ich glaube ja.
Und seit wann haben Sie Blutdruck?
Das ist schon länger, das sind fast 20 Jahre.
Gibt es noch etwas?
Ansonsten nicht, ich habe ab und zu mal ein bisschen Sod brennen.
Das kommt immer wieder mal.
Sod brennen?
Ja, und da gibt es so kleine gelbe Medikamente.
Wenn ich die nehme, dann geht es mir meistens besser.
Seit wann haben Sie jetzt Beschwerden?
Ich glaube, seit 30 Jahren.
Okay, sind Sie schon mal operiert worden?
Ja, ich hatte schon mehrere Operationen.
Was für Operationen hatten Sie?
Also zum einen ist Medikallenblase schon entfernt worden.
Da hatte ich Steine gehabt und die war entzündet.
Okay.
Und dann hatte ich mal einen Sportunfall.
Und beim Skifahren.
Ich hatte einen Schlüsselbeinfraktur.
Hier oben, da bin ich beim Skifahren gefallen
und das Schlüsselbein war gebrochen.
Wie wurden Sie behandelt?
Das wurde operiert, da ist eine Metallplatte eingelegt.
Okay, das war es.
Und ich habe so eine Hand, wie heißt das, wenn der Nerv eingeklemmt ist?
Kapaltunnel.
Genau, eine Kapaltunnel-Syndromatis.
Hier auf der rechten Seite.
Okay, Herr Dröhmig, gibt es in Ihrer Familie schwierige Erkrankungen?
Was meinen Sie mit schwierigen?
Zum Beispiel ein Blutverwärter zu Krankheiten.
Also Krebs gibt es einige Fälle.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, ich habe keine Ahnung, ich habe keine Ahnung.
Meine Onkel hatte Prostatakation.
Und da musste operiert werden.
Und lebt Ihre Mutter und Vater noch?
Meine Eltern leben noch.
Die haben glücklicherweise keine größeren Erkrankungen,
aber meine Mutter, der Arzt, die hat Anzeichen
von einer beginnenden Demenz.
Aber ansonsten geht es ihnen noch relativ gut.
Mein Vater ist fit, der hat nichts.
Aber meine Tante, die hat Brustkrebs gehabt.
Und meine andere Tante hatte vor einem Jahr einen Schlagabfall.
Und ist leider jetzt betlägerig.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Schlafen?
An sich nicht, das klappt relativ gut.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Das Problem ist zu gut.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Studiengang?
An sich nicht, das ist alles okay.
Herr Glöning, gibt es etwas, was Sie nicht belastet?
Wie meinen Sie das?
Haben Sie Stress in der Arbeit?
Natürlich, bei der Arbeit und so weit.
Aber das ist okay, das ist nichts Dramatisches.
Sie nehmen regelmäßig Kanadasatan,
amiosepin und metformin.
Nehmen Sie noch irgendwelche Kanadasatanen?
Nein, an sich nicht.
Wenn ich mal Schmerzen habe, dann nehme ich mal über Profin.
Aber habe ich jetzt längere Zeit auch nicht gehabt.
Brauchen Sie?
Hab und zu machen, nicht immer, aber manchmal.
Was meinen Sie denn?
Ich habe immer noch ein bis zwei Zigaretten am Tag.
Seit wann?
Ebigkeiten, über 30 Jahre.
Immer ein bis zwei Zigaretten?
Ja, manchmal auch gar nicht.
Aber so nach dem Abendessen manchmal.
Dann trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ab und zu mal.
Wie oft trinken Sie?
Ein Gläschen Wein am Abend.
Trink ich gerne mal.
Und dann auch mal ein Bier zwischendurch.
Nehmen Sie Drogen?
Drogen?
Nein, Drogen.
Ist bei Ihnen allergie bekannt?
Ja, mein Doktor meinte,
ich hatte mal einen Medikament bekommen,
ein Antibiotikum.
Aber ich habe den Namen vergessen.
Kann Penicillin sein?
Nein, das war ein anderes Antibiotikum.
Das hatte so einen komischen Namen.
Aber da kann ich noch mal nachgucken, das weiß ich nicht mehr.
Und ich habe auch so in früher
eine Polenallergie.
Was ist die Allergie?
Welche Allergie?
Ja, die Medikamente und die Polenallergie.
Auf die Medikamente habe ich einen ganz roten Ausschlag bekommen.
Ich hatte überall Juckreiz
und hatte Schwellungen am ganzen Körper.
Und die Polenallergie ist halt ganz typisch.
Da läuft mir die Nase.
Da trennen mir die Augen.
Das ist bei den Polen.
Ich möchte noch eine Frage stellen.
Was ist die Schmerzen,
die er hat oder die er stirbt?
Aktuell im Moment?
Genau.
Das kann ich jetzt nicht sagen.
Es ist nichts Besonderes.
Ich habe noch eine Frage.
Es ist schlimmer geworden.
Ich kann schlecht auf meinen Auftreten.
Ich hinke ein bisschen.
Wenn ich laufe, dann wird es schlimmer.
Beim Bewegung verschlimmert die Schmerzen.
Das ist richtig, genau.
Wie viele Meter können Sie laufen?
Nicht weit.
Ich habe nur 3-4 Meter.
Ich muss stehen bleiben, weil ich Schmerzen bekomme.
Vorher haben Sie so beschwerten?
Nein, dann hatte ich nicht.
Ich konnte ganz normal laufen.
Wenn Sie Ihre Beine hochlegen
und länger die Schmerzen...
Nein, das ändert sich nicht.
Wenn Sie ein Pause machen,
dann nachher können Sie wieder 3-4 Meter laufen.
Das bringt nicht sehr viel die Pause.
Ich muss kurz stehen bleiben.
Das ändert an den Schmerzen nicht sehr viel.
Das Beste ist sitzen.
Es gibt Ihre Beine.
Auf einer Wurde?
Nein, das habe ich nicht.
Herr Gröning, habe ich die wichtigsten Fragen gestellt?
Müssten Sie etwas ergänzen?
Nein, ich habe Angst, dass es wieder eine Trombose ist.
Deswegen bin ich da, dass Sie nachschauen.
Können Sie ein Ultraschall heute machen?
Herr Gröning, aber erst mal möchte ich die Körperversuchung versuchen.
Danach brauche ich eine Verluckungversuchung.
Ich nehme Ihnen einen Blutab.
Ich habe eine Verluckungversuchung.
Danach möchte ich Ihnen ein Ultraschall durchschauen.
Das ist ein Ultraschall.
Das kenne ich.
Je nach Ergebnisse,
können wir auch eine Angiografie
durchschauen.
Ich hoffe nicht.
Ich habe eine Verluckungversuchung.
Ich hoffe, dass es keine Trombose ist.
Das macht mir wieder Angst.
Wir müssen die ersten Ergebnisse überprüfen.
Danach können wir nachher
doppelwäschrig machen.
Ich kenne das.
Ich muss jetzt ein bisschen warten.
Vielen Dank, Herr Doktor, für Ihre Zeit.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Dann setze ich mich in die zweite.
Danke.
Noch Fragen?
Kollegen sind alle zufrieden.
Dann brauche ich eine Minute Zeit.
Haben die anderen Kolleginnen und Kollegen noch Fragen?
Keine Frage.
Sie wissen alle, was es ist.
Ich möchte von Ihnen mindestens 2
Differenzialdiagnosen wissen.
Ich?
Ich bin bereit.
Dann bitte schön.
Guten Tag, Herr Oberarzt.
Wenn Sie Zeit haben, möchte ich Ihnen
einen neuen Patienten vorstellen.
Guten Tag, Servus.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Sie sind mal los.
Herr Gräulich ist ein 54-jähriger Patient.
94 kg.
175 cm groß.
Er klagt über
seit 2 Tagen zunehmende
Schmerzen an der rechten Bade.
Unter
Schmerzen.
Die Bade
sind in den letzten 2 Tagen
groß geworden.
Er
hat
vorher mehrmals
eine große Geschichte.
Er hatte
Er hatte eine große Geschichte.
Er hat 10 Jahre,
Linkenbein,
die dritten Kompose.
Aber eine Gerätungssstörung
würde bei ihm nicht festgestellt.
Das ist schon durchgeführt worden.
Er Besuch regelnmäßig
Er trägt eine Stromfrosse.
Einen Kompressionstrumpf.
Kompressionstrumpf.
Und außerdem, er kann nicht laufen wegen der Schmerzen.
Er kann nur 3-4 Meter laufen, danach treten die Schmerzen auf.
Er hat 3 Tage einen Reise gemacht.
Er musste 4 Stunden fahren.
Danach sind alle Beschwerden aufgeschrieben.
Ja, auf ja alles klar.
Also in der Vorgeschichte liegt Artäria-Legitatur-Ni.
Und Diabetes-Medizin 2-Telfo.
Und in der Familienanmese liegt bei der Mutter Alzheimer
und bei dem Onkel Frustratacatinum
und bei der Kante Mammacatinum
und auch die andere Kante hat der Schlaganfall.
Also apoplexisch.
Vegetative an einem Näsig ist unauffällig.
Er nimmt regelmäßig Kandesatan, 16 Milligramm morgens
und 1 Millipin, 5 Milligramm abends
und 500 Milligramm morgens und abends
und bei Bedarf über Profilienfabrierein.
Genussmittel ist nicht relevant für uns.
Er raucht 1-2 Skarretten am Tag seit 30 Jahren
und er trinkt ein Glas Bier abends.
Er ist allergisch gegen eine Medikamente,
aber er erinnert sich nicht die Name
und er ist allergisch auch gegen Folgen.
Also nach den bisherigen Angaben gehe ich um eine Tief-Benthrombose aus.
Von einem Rezidiv einer tiefen Bi-Benthrombose.
Der hatte es ja schon mal gehabt.
Die Franziare Diagnostik kommt zum Beispiel ein PHVK
oder ein Celilitis.
Eine was?
Ein Celilitis.
Celilitis, okay.
Ja.
Wir sehen sich ganz noch Celilitis, wenn die Haut infiziert wird.
Ein großer Infekt der Haut.
Infektion der Haut, können die Kollegen helfen?
Ermatitis.
Bitte?
Der Ermatitis.
Der Ermatitis, wie nennt sich das noch?
Ersippat.
Ja, sehr gut.
Ein Eresipel.
Sehr gut.
Also eine weitere Differenzialdiagnose, ein Eresipel.
Was noch?
Ein Eresipel.
Das kann ein beginnender Unkurs grüles sein,
weil der Patient hat diabetes.
Ah, okay.
Ja, und so was muss man denken, richtig.
Und, was ich vielleicht vergessen habe zu sagen,
und das hätten Sie sehen müssen, er hat Varizen.
An beiden Unterschenkeln.
Eine Varikosis.
Ja, eine Varikosis.
Woran muss man dann denken?
Wenn die Oberflächlichen Venen entzündet sind, wie heißt das?
Fläbo-Trombose.
Trombo-Flabitis.
Trombo-Flabitis, genau.
Er hat gesagt, dass die eine Venen sehr hart ist,
wenn man drauf drückt.
Also man muss auch eine Trombo-Flabitis denken, richtig.
Sehr gut.
Das waren so die wichtigsten Differenzialdiagnosen.
Ich hatte diese Woche also einen Patienten,
und er hat eine Trombo-Flabitis, wahrscheinlich.
Den haben wir jetzt noch mal zum Angelogen geschickt.
Muss man eine Trombo-Flabitis, oder wie behandeln Sie eine Trombo-Flabitis?
Jetzt war ich mal so.
Eine Entzündung der Oberflächlichen Venen.
Nicht der tiefen Beinvenen, sondern der Oberflächliche.
Also erst mal muss man unbedingt eine Mutversöhnung anbinden.
Muss man?
Oder?
Bei einer Oberflächlichen? Nein.
Nein.
Also bei der tiefen Beinvenen-Trombose müssen Sie antikoagulieren.
Das ist richtig.
Und eine Kompression durchführen, also eine Kompression.
Das ist bei der tiefen Beinvenen-Trombose, der TVT.
Bei der Oberflächlichen Venen-Entzündung brauchen Sie kein,
nicht unbedingt eine Blutverdünnung.
Das macht man nur, wenn diese Oberflächliche Venen-Entzündung
sehr ausgeprägt ist oder sehr groß ist,
dann kann man das vorübergehen,
eine kurze Zeit machen.
Muss man aber nicht.
Man gibt eher Schmerz-Pompemente,
nicht stehloridale Antirolematiker, Entzündungshemmer.
Man macht einen Kompression-Stumpf
und man kann auch vielleicht eine Heparin-Salbe benutzen.
Das ist der fein Unterschied.
Bei der tiefen Beinvenen-Trombose muss man antikoagulieren.
Bei der Oberflächlichen muss man nicht.
Je nach Ausprägung kann man kurzfristig antikoagulieren.
Für diesen Patienten auch, weil der vorgeschickt ist.
Genau, das ist ein besonderer Fall.
Ich habe bei den Patienten trotzdem eine Antikoagulation angeschangen,
aufgrund dieser Vorgeschichte.
Weil er schon mal mehrfach Trombosen hatte
und auch schon einmal Nungenembuddy.
Ich wollte auf Nummer Sicher gehen.
Ich wollte eine Sicherheit und habe ihn trotzdem antikoaguliert.
Ich habe ihn zum Angiologen geschickt,
dass er einen genauen Ultraschall macht.
Nachschaut, ob auch die tiefen Beinvenen schon betroffen sind.
Bei einer Oberflächlichen-Wähnen-Entzündung
muss man eigentlich nicht immer Antibiotika geben.
Vorhin kam die Frage.
Das hängt davon ab, wie ausgeprägt da ist.
Ob die Haut vielleicht im Sinne eines leichten,
beginnenden Erisipäels entzündet ist,
kann man einen Penicillin-Verfahrt geben.
Aber beim Erisipäel gibt man natürlich ein Antibiotikum.
Das ist richtig.
Wie ist es, Herr Doktor?
Darf der Patient laufen, wenn er eine Tromboflibitis hat
oder eine Trombose?
Darf er sich belasten?
Oder muss er Ruhe einhalten?
Nein.
Man muss die Beine erst mal hochlegen.
Sollte die Patienten die Beine hochlegen,
Hochlage und erst mal weniger belasten, glaube ich.
Wer kennt sich aus, haben wir Spezialisten unter uns,
von den Zuhörenden, Ärzten und Ärzten,
tiefe Beinwähntromose.
Darf der Patient belasten oder nicht?
Mobilisierung, sagt der eine Kollege, Herr Tschade.
Was sagen die anderen?
Sechs Wochen Pause, gibt es?
Immobilisation, keiner sagt was.
Keiner traut sich.
Also Herr Tschade war sehr mutig und er hat Recht.
Früher hat man die tiefe Beinwähntromose
im Mobil gehalten, aber das stimmt nicht mehr.
Die Patienten können sich mobilisieren,
die sollen sich auch mobilisieren.
Aber die brauchen einen Kompression, eine Kompression Strumpf
und eine Antikorbulation.
Dann können sie mobilisieren.
Die sollen jetzt nicht unbedingt Sport treiben,
aber die können laufen und mobilisieren.
Das ist richtig.
Bei der Tromboflibitis sowieso,
die können auch mobilisieren.
Beim Enrysipel auch,
so lagen sie keine Schmerzen.
Sehr gut Herr Tschade, ein Pluspunkt, der sagt nichts mehr.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Siebt noch Fragen oder Kritiken?
Vorschläge, keine Vorschläge.
Alle sind glücklich, alle sind zufrieden.
Alle sagen, Dr. Emre war heute sehr gut.
Und der letzte Prüfung in Stalach bestehen.
Wo ist die Prüfung?
Wo?
In Mainz.
Wo wohnen Sie?
In Kaiserslautern.
Nach der Prüfung sehen wir uns,
trinken wir einen Kaffee in Kaiserslautern.
Sie sind in Lützdach, ich weiß.
Okay, kommen wir.
Wir sind nicht sehr weit.
Ok, tukte sheküldürum war sehr gut.
Auch dank an Herrn Dr. Tschade,
was sind Sie für ein Facharzt Dr. Tschade?
Wo ist Dr. Tschade?
Wir sind ein Autopäde, sehr gut.
Sehr schön, jetzt kenn ich Sie,
wir hatten doch schon mal das Glück gehabt.
Sehr gut, sehr gut.
Vielen Dank, Herr Dr.
Dann wünsche Ihnen allen und auch den Kollegen,
einen schönen Abend, viel Erfolg bei den Prüfungen.